The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
we're going to talk
about the dynamics of running.
And ask questions as
freely as possible,
and also if my handwriting's
bad, let me know.
It generally is.
So.
So this is actually
a really fun lecture.
We have a lot of cool videos.
I don't know if any of you have
seen Raibert hoppers and stuff
before, but we have some cool
models and some cool analysis
too.
So hopefully,
you'll be as excited
as I am to participate in
this learning experience.
So here we go.
So the basic model
we'll be looked
at today in several
different versions of this
is the SLIP model.
This is the spring-loaded
inverted pendulum.
All right.
It's like the running version
of the rimless wheel or compass
gait.
It's pretty simple.
You just have a mass at
the end of a pendulum.
You have a spring here,
spring constant k.
The spring is a rest
length r naught and a--
yeah, we already said
the spring constant.
And so then this--
the coordinates,
then, are this length r and the
angle theta from the upright.
So what we're going to
want to look at here
is not just this
model, but also,
in the same way we had for the
rimless wheel, as you remember,
is a 1-D iterated map.
So you probably remember that
for the compass gait that
lets you look at
the stability of it,
and there's all these
interesting dynamics that are
captured by that simple system.
So we're going to want to
look at the 1-D iterated map,
and the other thing I'm
going to try to convince you
is that this is a
biologically plausible system.
So if you look at
the rimless wheel,
it feels like something
that's walking,
compass gait even more
so, [INAUDIBLE] knees.
These things all--
just intuitively,
you can believe that they're--
sorry-- a-- whoa, that's
probably going to be bad--
that you could believe that
they're walking systems.
But this one maybe doesn't
seem to you immediately
like a running system.
Maybe it seems like a jumping
system or bouncing system
or something, but
actually, it actually
is a pretty good model
for running systems.
So the two things that we're
going to have to go through,
how do you get a
1-D iterated map?
Now that maybe is a
bit surprising for you
because if you look at
this, the full state
space of this inverted pendulum
right now, it has states of r--
sorry-- r theta,
r dot, theta dot.
Now that's four parameters.
You remember when
you slice through
and you pick a
surface of section,
you can cut it down by one.
So for the rimless wheel, maybe
you have theta, theta dot.
You cut out theta dot,
you're in pretty good shape.
Here we have four,
but we're actually
going to show that we can
actually get this down
to a 1-D system
and actually look
at the iterated map for this.
So that's kind of cool.
And the other thing is
that also, this system
bounces and takes
off, so actually, we
need two coordinate systems.
One is this r theta,
r dot, theta dot.
And then when it's
in flight, we're
going to have x, y, x
dot, y dot, all right.
And both of these
are 4-D, so going
to have to deal with
that either way.
But first the convincing part.
So the justification here
comes from a field called
comparative biomechanics.
Now this is a pretty cool field.
They look at all sorts
of different systems
and try to figure out these
commonalities in the kinematics
or the dynamics or certain
properties and figure out,
what are the fundamental
common features
of these different
biological systems?
So this running
model, actually, you
can look at it in the context of
things from cockroaches, which
are on the order of a
gram in mass, horses,
which are on the order of--
well, some of them, at
least, are 135 kilograms.
It's not that heavy, really,
so you could imagine maybe
heavier horses.
Crabs.
Now you can think about the
kinematics of these system
and just how wildly
different they are.
Cockroaches, six-legged,
bouncing all around,
[INAUDIBLE] tripod gait.
Horses, quadrupeds.
Crabs, actually they run
sideways with eight legs.
This is different information,
so I won't put it there.
But crabs actually
will run sideways
using their eight legs.
It's actually pretty cool.
I don't know if you've seen it.
And then humans, which maybe
is the one that we most--
well, I don't know, that's
probably unfairly biocentric.
So we're humans.
And all of these, despite the
very different kinematics,
despite, what is this, five
orders of magnitude in mass,
they all have incredible
dynamic similarity.
Let's hope I'm not getting
graded on spelling, because I'm
pretty sure that's way off.
[INAUDIBLE] And so if you
look at it in the right way,
you can actually see that all
of these systems, cockroaches,
horses, crabs, camels, cats,
bunny rabbits, all these things
actually look very similar.
And so Bob Full, some of
you may know Bob Full,
I think at Berkeley.
He looks at a lot of things,
especially the cockroach work.
He has a lot of cool
work on cockroaches.
And he also has
this paper which--
let's see if I can
find what page this on.
Sorry, here.
There we go.
Is that clear up there?
Ooh.
Sorry.
So here, you can
look at the-- oh,
let me dim the lights a bit.
If you look at the
plot on the left,
this is speed and
the stride length.
So if you plot speed and
stride lengths-- here
they've got gerbils,
dogs, and camels,
but you can do this for a
very wide variety of systems.
You can see that they're
all bounced over the place.
You don't have--
I mean, they're all
behaving very differently,
so that's not
necessarily the right way
to look at them if you want
to see what is fundamentally
similar between them.
If you look at the right, this
is the [INAUDIBLE] number.
In this case, you can
see it's just the ratio--
well, it's 2 times the
ratio of kinetic energy
to potential energy.
So it's just this
non-dimensional quantity.
If you plot this and you look
at the relative stride length,
which is--
you can see they all collapse
very tightly on this line.
And so there's actually--
that's impressive agreement.
You see that these are--
camels, dogs, and
gerbils are all--
look very similar
when you look at them
in this non-dimensional way.
So all these systems,
orders of magnitude,
again, of difference in masses,
stride lengths too, probably,
all look very similar
when you compare them
in the right framework.
And that's what
comparative biomechanics
tries to do, in addition
to other things, obviously.
So here's something
that's really cool
and that connects us
back to our SLIP model.
If we look at the
next page, you'll
see right here, here in--
this is the relative
spring constant
for individual individual
leg [INAUDIBLE] systems,
cockroach to kangaroo,
five orders of magnitude.
You can see that they're
all pretty similar.
This is huge spectrum
of masses, and yet
in the framework of
the SLIP model's spring
constant, they all
behave pretty similarly,
humans, all these things.
And so if you look
at these systems
through this simple
model, they all not only
look similar to one another, but
their dynamics and their center
of mass [INAUDIBLE] are
pretty well described
by this kind of behavior.
Sorry.
By that kind of behavior.
So hopefully that will be
somewhat compelling argument
that this model
is representative
of actual running behavior,
not just something
that comes out of nowhere.
And a lot of work was done
on this in the '80s and '90s
on trying to study this model
and connect it to animals
and that sort of stuff.
I don't know if you've
seen Raibert's work,
but he has robots that are very
similar to these sort of SLIP
model that run and
jump and actually
are from the '80s and such
like that actually are
some of the really cool robots.
And I'll show you some of those.
So he actually didn't
even call them SLIP.
He actually made
them before SLIP,
and that motivated some of
the work on SLIP models.
But I can show.
Here, I'll show you
a picture of a robot
so you can see the kind of cool
stuff that we're getting to.
I don't know if--
are many of you familiar
with the Leg Lab?
They should be around.
Yeah, they had a
lot of cool robots.
And here, see if I can give
you just a little picture
[INAUDIBLE] Ah.
Oh, so that's the biped robot.
This thing's bouncing, but
that's not really the picture
I wanted to show you.
Ah, here we go.
Yeah.
So this little robot, you can
see that's tracing its foot.
This up here is tracing
its center mass.
And you see how center mass
actually compresses right
above the foot.
And that's what you expect here.
It lands, and it squishes down.
And so instead of
when you're walking
and you vault over
this leg-- like you
think about that rimless wheel.
Its center mass rolls
up over its foot.
This one, both intuitively
in the model and you
can see right here
this robot, which
is similar to the
model in many ways,
is squishing down into
its foot, all right.
And that actually
is one of the ways
of looking at the difference
between what is running,
what is walking.
So one of the
definitions for running
is that you're supposed
to have an aerial phase.
But not every running
animal has an aerial phase.
So this is-- actually, I think
comparative biomechanicians
look at this center of mass to
center of pressure trajectory,
because--
I don't know if you
know Groucho Marx.
Groucho Marx had this funny run.
Maybe I'll do it.
So [INAUDIBLE] but
sort of like this--
you know?
That kind of goofy
thing where your feet
aren't coming up the ground?
That doesn't seem natural.
But actually, some
animals do that.
There's actually elephants
that do that Groucho run.
So maybe if you're big
enough, it makes sense.
But yeah, so [INAUDIBLE] this
is very different from walking.
And it's actually quite
similar to running,
and actually, if you
look at these animals,
it captures a lot
of their dynamics.
So and another
important thing is
that these kind of robots
which came around in the '80s
were the similar kind of work
in robotics, because again,
the same time [INAUDIBLE] these
slow, careful walking robots.
Again, here are
these robots that
are flying through the air.
I'll show you some
videos later, but they
did flips and all
kinds of crazy stuff.
I mean, they're throwing
themselves around wildly,
which is not what people
thought of when they
thought of these legged robots.
Oh, and the other thing--
this is cool too.
If you look at
animals, like we're
talking about this springs
and stuff like that,
that's not just some
sort of obtuse model
that comes out of nowhere.
If you look at horses and
stuff, well, animals, actually,
are full of springs.
Their tendons can store
up energy and stuff.
And actually, horses
have a big tendon
that runs through their leg
all the way up, I think,
behind their hip.
And apparently, one of
the limiting factors
of trying to run fast is that
you can't pull your leg forward
fast enough to get
to the next stride.
And so what they
actually can do is
they can preload
when they're pushing,
and then that tendon
actually acts like a spring.
It actually stores
energy and lets
them swing faster than they
would be able to if they just
used the motor.
And if you look at the oxygen
intake of these animals,
you can see that they're
behaving much more
efficiently than you could hope
to accomplish if you just had--
if you were simulating a
spring with a bunch of motor--
with your muscles
acting like a spring.
So it's actually they're
physical springs.
Actually, this tendon
in there actually
have this actual behavior.
So hopefully-- maybe I'm
dwelling on that point
too much, but I think
that's really cool,
that these animals actually have
this kind of spring behavior.
You can see it in
their dynamics,
and actually, this model
captures a lot of that.
Oh, and here's one other
thing that Russ [INAUDIBLE]
and it's pretty cool, too.
If you think about--
this is sort of
tangent, but if you
think about how birds
sit on purchase forever,
right, I mean, it
seems like that'd
be tiring to be able to hang
there forever just squeezing,
right?
But they actually
have tendons, too,
such that when they
sit on the perch
and their weight
squishes their legs down,
it actually will clamp their
talons in and let them hold on.
So that's cool, too,
that these animals
have all these interesting
passive structures and springs,
stuff like that, that help them
do all these kind of things.
And so it's not like the,
just use your muscles
and just dominate, all
these kind of things.
There's a lot of
passive structures
that do a lot of this for free.
So hopefully, you all
think that's awesome.
All right.
All right, so getting
back to the system.
Looking at this-- sorry--
at this model again--
did you see where
I put my chalk?
All right.
So going back to
the SLIP system--
let's see.
Again, the state space here--
is it-- yeah, it's
still dark in here.
So going back to this
system, again, we
have r theta, r dot, theta dot,
and in the aerial phase, x, y,
x dot, y dot.
All right, I'll bring
this one back down.
And let me put in the
assumptions really clearly
of what this model
is going to have,
so the assumptions
for the SLIP model.
So one is that you
have a massless--
whoa, that's terrible--
massless leg and toe.
All right?
So all your mass is
concentrated in that [INAUDIBLE]
at the body.
You have an ideal lossless
spring in your leg.
And what that means,
that effectively,
your collisions with the ground,
unlike all the walking models,
are perfectly elastic.
All right?
And now you can see that that's
not an extra assumption that
is derived from these.
When it hits, even though
this toe sticks in right away
and [INAUDIBLE] inelastic
collision with that toe,
because there's no mass
there, there's no energy,
there's not momentum in it--
sorry.
This is [INAUDIBLE] you
don't lose any energy.
And so it's actually
conservative
as it runs through.
And then if you--
it's flying through
the air, there's
no drag or anything,
that's conservative when it
flies through the air as well.
And so this system
actually is completely
conservative in
its full operation.
So yeah, so it's very
different than a rimless wheel.
And also, then the other
assumption we have to make
is that the leg instantly goes
to the desired theta and rest
length.
So again, when it's
massless, the rest length,
it will do that automatically.
But you have to assume
that [INAUDIBLE]
teleported to that theta.
So you don't worry about
collisions with the ground
or everything like that.
Your leg just goes to
the theta touchdown.
So the moment you take off,
it's in this new configuration.
So now what we
have to do is, now
that we have the
system and the model,
we want to pick our
surface of section,
because our goal here is to turn
this into a 1-D iterated map,
right, because that's
what this is all about.
We're going to
try to figure out,
how do we pick a spot where you
can just look at one section
and describe all the
dynamics, just being like,
OK, we're here.
Simulate to the next one.
And then we can just
iterate this map
and figure out the fixed points,
figure out a lot of things,
as we did with
the rimless wheel.
So does anyone have an idea of
what a good surface of section
would be?
No?
What special configurations
are there that we can look at?
AUDIENCE: Take-off.
PROFESSOR: Take-off.
What else?
That's one.
AUDIENCE: Full compression.
PROFESSOR: Full com--
AUDIENCE: Or rest
length [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: At the rest length?
That's true.
Full compression you
could do, but that
would be like there'd be a 0
r dot or something like that.
But yeah.
No, I mean, you could.
There's a lot of these
special configurations.
But the one that you
really want to look at,
the one that collapses
things down the most
is if you look at the apex.
So you look at the maximum
height of this flight.
So we can just look at that y.
And the reason we can do this
I can describe right here.
So we look in the flight phase.
Now, first of all,
x, we don't really
care about what x is
for the stability.
Doesn't matter where it
is along that position.
That doesn't affect
the dynamics directly.
So we don't care about x.
So y, we definitely
do care about.
This matters.
x dot, well, x dot, because
we know it's conservative
and we know that since at
the apex y dot equals 0,
then x dot is purely a
function of y, right?
We can look at the total
energy of the system, which
is 1/2 m V squared plus mgy.
We know y dot is 0, so that
means that V is just x dot.
And so you can write x
dot is a function of y.
And so here, we know this is 0.
We don't care about this.
This one we can find
directly from y.
And so everything that happens
between one apex, another apex,
we know if we just know y.
You see that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We're always
adjusting the angles [INAUDIBLE]
landing so that it is
vertical at the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's set at whatever
desired angle we're at.
So there's some nominal angle
we want on this touchdown.
So let's say it's 30
degrees or whatever.
And so that means
that then you take off
and your angle-- your
leg goes to 30 degrees,
and then you hit there.
And so the touchdown
angle is always the same.
And so there's no control
in this at the moment.
It's just the passive stability
of this balancing system.
Does that makes
sense to everyone
how we can collapse
all these things?
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] why
don't we care about x again?
Because--
PROFESSOR: Because
that doesn't affect
the stability of the system.
So if we're trying to get
somewhere and hit a target,
yeah, then we have to look
at x in our controller.
But because the x doesn't
figure in the dynamics anywhere,
right, doesn't matter,
because again--
sorry, this is something
I probably should have
mentioned in the beginning.
It's not going downhill
or anything like that.
So how far it goes
in x doesn't matter.
The dynamics are going to be
the same invariant to that,
if that makes sense.
And so because of that, I
mean, x will be changing,
but it won't affect
the next apex height,
because it doesn't figure
into the dynamics like that.
Does that make sense?
All right.
So we can represent the
whole thing just using y.
I guess that's the
important thing to realize.
So what do I want to erase?
I'll erase this stuff.
I'll throw this back up.
Hmm.
This isn't ideal.
All right, this is not going
to get better than that.
All right.
So we just go through
this transition
and we go from apex
to apex, we can
look at is we have y apex at n.
Then we need to figure out how
that translates into the y,
x dot, and y dot at that apex.
All right, so we need to map
this one piece of information
into all of these.
And then we can map
that into the y,
x dot, y dot at the touchdown,
so when it comes in and hits.
Now we have to change our
coordinate system to r theta,
r dot, theta dot.
This is still a touchdown,
and we swing that
through in the stance phase.
Then we get that to r theta,
r dot, theta dot at take-off.
So my D and my O are
as different as I
can make them look.
Then at take-off again, we
switch to our aerial phase.
We go back to y, x
dot, y dot at takeoff.
And that brings us, then, to
a y, x dot, y dot at apex.
And then here, of course,
we grab y n plus 1 at apex.
[PHONE RINGING]
So these transitions,
I'll number of them
and make this a
little bit clearer.
That's one, two, three, four.
Sorry.
So all right.
And the key now is
to figure out how
to push our system throughout
all these transitions
so we can figure out what
this mapping is going to be.
So some of these are pretty
easy to do, and some of them
can be quite tricky to do.
But all of them are
quite manageable.
So what you look at first
is the energy, which
is our kinetic plus
potential, again,
is 1/2 mv squared plus mgy.
So at the first step,
if you want to convert--
if we want to take y apex and
turn it into these guys again,
we can have the
energy of the apex
we know is 1/2 m x dot, again,
because we know y dot 0,
plus mgy is equal to a constant.
And so then this
means that we can say,
all right, x dot equals
this function of y.
So we can figure
out what x dot is,
[INAUDIBLE] and
then we know also--
sorry.
We know y dot equals 0.
And so here, then, that
gets our first transition.
Two then, if we want--
we know that x
dot at touchdown--
so this is the ballistic
phase coming down from apex--
is equal to x dot apex, because
there's no forces on it,
so it's just going to keep
carrying forward in x.
And then we know y touchdown
is going to be r naught cosine
theta naught.
So this is what I
was talking about
with there's the desired theta.
So your touchdown,
you know you're
going to touch down
at this desired theta.
And this, then, again,
since we know our energy,
we can get y dot
touchdown, all right.
So here that gets our transition
from apex to touchdown.
Now this is just a
coordinate transformation.
It's pretty easy to do.
Just make sure you get
your velocities right.
You have to decompose
them properly.
But you can just transform
those coordinates,
and then you get that
without too much difficulty.
But then you get to the tricky
one, and the tricky one--
[INAUDIBLE] The tricky
one is the stance phase.
So how do you push yourself
from when you come in
and hit to squishing down
and launching back out?
So that's the
involved part of this.
So four is stance dynamics.
AUDIENCE: Is that y a
touchdown [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: y [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah,
this is touchdown.
Sorry.
So to get to two, to
get this falling phase,
you know x doesn't change.
There's no forces
in the x direction.
y touchdown, you fix this angle.
That's instantaneous
warp of the leg.
So you know when
it touches down,
it's going to be this
high, because that's
when touchdown's defined, is
when the toe hits the ground.
And then here, you
know your height.
You know this.
And again,
conservation of energy
will give you this at
the y dot touchdown
since that just allows
you to figure out
your state when you come in.
So stance dynamics.
So here, you've
got a idea of what
you expect the system to do.
You have a spring.
And if you're running
in steady state,
I believe you take off the
same angle you come in.
But so what you
can imagine happens
is this thing swings around like
this, but the center of mass
goes in and comes back out.
So again, it's doing
that compression
and then launching
itself, all right.
So I think it's a
assumption Raibert did
for the steady state operation.
It comes in, out
at the same angle,
and serves as a
compression in the middle.
And so again, this
kind of behavior
is, again, one of those
ways of defining running,
like for the Groucho
kind of running,
is that you see
the center of mass
come in to the
center of pressure,
as opposed to vaulting over it.
If this was a stiff leg,
it would go like this.
So that distinction is one
way of defining running.
So we can define take-off, so
we know our final condition.
So take-off happens
when r equals r naught.
So when you get back
to your rest length,
you assume that your
body then, it goes back
to the ballistic phase.
All right, then we can write
down our energies here.
Now again, we're in
the polar coordinates
now, so our energies look
a little bit different.
Our kinetic energy
looks like that,
and our potential energy is this
term, and what else do we need?
What else?
AUDIENCE: Spring potential.
PROFESSOR: Spring, yeah.
So it's k over 2 x-- sorry--
r minus r naught squared.
And so using that, you
probably remember Lagrange.
It's not that bad of a system.
You can get the
equations of motion.
The equation of
motion here, you get--
oh, sorry.
And so you have all
your expected terms,
centrifugal terms,
Coriolis terms, all
that if you try to make
sense of what this is.
And so if you want to get
from touchdown to take-off,
you can't get a closed
form solution from this.
You can simulate pretty
easily, obviously.
But you don't get
the closed form,
so you can't get this
analytical kind of mapping.
But if you use a small
angle and small displacement
approximation, you can
linearize the system,
and you can get a closed form
solution for this touchdown
to take-off phase, all right.
And so that's this assumption
that theta is much,
much less than 1.
Your delta r over r0
is much less than 1.
And so then you can get
to a closed form solution.
It's kind of ugly.
It's not really ugly.
I mean, it's not so ugly
as to be prohibitive,
but I'm not going
to write it down.
But that lets you actually
get a closed form return
map, all right.
And something cool
about that is that you
get these two fixed points.
You get one stable fixed point
and one unstable fixed point.
And-- hmm.
And actually, a number
of people thought
that a system like this,
this conservative system,
shouldn't be able to get
that sort of stability,
because if you remember
in the rimless wheel,
the energy loss was
critical towards achieving
the stability.
When you went faster, you hit
harder, you lost more energy.
And when you went slower,
you didn't lose much energy,
so you were able to speed up
as you went down this ramp.
So the fact that you can
achieve stability in this system
is kind of cool, too, because
it's completely conservative,
yet somehow, dynamics are
able to actually push it
towards a repeatable state.
[INAUDIBLE] an then looking at--
we're going to see
this return map.
This is from [INAUDIBLE]
Geyer's thesis work, I believe.
And it's pretty cool, if
I can get to it for you.
There we go.
So this is actually
the return map
for this small
angle approximation
you can get analytically.
And you see there's this
unstable fixed point,
and then down there, there's
that stable fixed point.
So you zoom in, and you can
see the stability region,
that that unstable one
is defining the boundary
of the stability for that.
The apex height, why does it
get to that minimum there?
Why doesn't it go
below that 0.87?
Anyone know?
Why don't we look
at it below that?
AUDIENCE: Because that's
the maximum range?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's your
height at the cosine theta
length of the leg.
And so you can't get below that.
And then the weird
thing is, and this
is something I was talking
about with Russ just
before he went
home, was why does
it keep climbing like that?
AUDIENCE: Why does it
keep climbing [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, because
this is conservative.
So how can you
have an instability
that pushes you up to larger
and larger apex heights?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
to a more vertical--
PROFESSOR: At some point,
though, it should cap.
There should be another stable
fixed point bouncing straight
up.
There isn't.
The thing is that,
what we think is
that that unstable
one right there is
your vertical bouncing.
And the thing is that, actually,
when you linearize these,
they don't quite
conserve energy anymore.
This actually can be a
non-conservative term.
So we think that's
what this is from.
So it really shouldn't
be climbing up like that,
because when you
simulate these things,
you don't get above
that second fixed point.
It rolls up to
this unstable one.
And so then-- but
looking at this again,
now here's another
strange thing.
It looks like it should be
globally stable, then, right?
Because if in
practice we can't get
above that unstable
fixed point--
and if you look at this apex
axis, right, the higher it is,
the slower it moves.
So at your minimum apex
height, right, that's
when you're moving fastest.
It looks like it's stable
throughout the entire operating
regime, right?
The fastest it can move is
that little guy on the far left
where it's apparently stable.
And the slowest it can move
is this vertical bouncing,
[INAUDIBLE] fixed point.
So how do you explain that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
the thing is that it--
that's pretty much
exactly the issue
is that your failure mode can
come from coming in, squishing
really low--
I'm going to fall
in my face here,
so I should let everyone see it.
You can compress
and get really low,
and then you bounce forward.
And if you bounce forward
at such a directory
that you never get high
enough for your leg
to be out, touch it
down, then you're
just going to bounce
forward, land on your face.
You can't actually
warp your leg.
Does that make sense?
So that can be
your failure mode.
So you bounce in,
you shoot across,
and then if you never
have an apex high enough,
you'll never get your
leg ahead of you.
So that's the failure mode.
So that's actually then what
we see when we simulate it.
And the simulation actually
looks a little bit different.
There's actually-- this
guy looks pretty good,
but if you simulate
it and you have
slightly different
parameters, that
curve there comes down
a little bit lower,
and so you're actually
able to be from the top
and bounce in and
overshoot and go unstable.
So it's not like you're
guaranteed stability
by starting to bounce
vertically, either.
So this will change
with different energies,
different parameter settings,
and everything like that.
But the takehome thing
I think that's cool
is that, even this
simplified perspective of it,
you get this stability in
this conservative system.
You get this stability that
you can see in the simulation,
and that even though it's
not dampening on any energy
or anything like that,
is able to bounce
along and right itself.
And apparently, what that's
related to-- apparently,
people didn't used to
think that was possible.
But the coordinate
transform is actually
enough to get that kind
of stability, is that--
it's called piecewise holonomic.
And by switching
these coordinates,
you're actually
able to get the--
that allows the dynamics
to stabilize themselves,
apparently, as opposed to
a normal holonomic system
apparently couldn't
actually converge in back
towards this fixed point.
If you think about the
pendulum [INAUDIBLE]
like that, that's not going
to converge [INAUDIBLE]
It has to conserve the energy.
But apparently, with
piecewise holonomic systems,
it's available.
But you can read some
papers and get into that.
But I don't know much
more than I just told you.
All right, so here's another
thing that's interesting,
is that if you look at-- if
you want to model those Raibert
hoppers, right, they obviously
aren't completely conservative.
They do have some mass in
the toe and in the leg,
and so when they hit,
they do lose some energy,
because when that toe hits
and sticks to the ground,
it's going to be a
dissipative reaction.
So you can look at
this model by, I think,
[INAUDIBLE] and Buehler in '91.
I'm going to use
my big chalk again.
Ah, and here's my old big chalk.
So looking at this.
So here we have a toe mass.
So we have the mass of the
body and mass of the toe.
And this spring can possibly
be non-linear if you want.
And this was largely-- they did
some analytics, but a lot of it
was computationally
driven, the analysis
they did of this system.
And so the thing is,
because of this hit here,
you have a loss due
to the toe mass.
So must add energy.
And I do this with a
control on the spring.
You can vary your spring
constant like that.
You can add energy
to the system.
And so the control in the spring
is their only control then.
And you actually can get
similar stability properties
to the SLIP model.
You can get these
when you simulate it.
You can find the same stable
fixed point, unstable fixed
point kind of behavior.
And so this is all what
we've been talking about.
The image we have is this
sagittal plane dynamics, right?
The sagittal plane is this
plane, and so this idea
of running through like that.
Getting a little
bit aerial phase so
I look less ridiculous.
And so the other thing,
though, is that it's
good for the lateral plane.
If you look at the lateral
plane dynamics, certain animals,
the same kind of SLIP model
and that kind of behavior
can actually be witnessed.
So this is, again, something
Bob Full spend a lot of time on.
If you look at a cockroach,
which has a tripod gait--
here's a cockroach.
I wish they actually
looked like that.
Probably wouldn't
be as disturbing.
There.
And so what you have is, they
use three legs at a time,
and they're springy legs.
As it runs, if you
look at the dynamics,
you actually can see the--
you actually can see that these
legs are acting like springs.
And actually, the same
SLIP behavior you'd expect,
you witness in the cockroaches.
And so there's some
cool things here.
Let me show you.
So these-- have any of
you heard of preflex,
as opposed to reflex?
It's like pithy kind
of name, I guess.
So the preflex is where
actually, you can actually
look at the time
constant required
for the monosynaptic reflex,
which is the electrical signal
to go through and actually
to the spinal cord and back.
So not to the brain and
to the full path, but just
the quick reflex
kind of response.
And actually, some
of these creatures
actually respond
faster than that.
So the theory is, is
that it's actually
a musculoskeletal response.
So it's not even-- it's
not controlled at all.
It's not going to the muscles
or anything like that.
It's tendons.
It's the springiness in the leg.
And that is actually what's
providing some of the control
here and some of the stability.
And so there's a really
incredibly awesome video
that I am definitely
going to show you,
regardless of how inconvenient
this thing comes out.
AUDIENCE: It's not an
anticipatory neural.
PROFESSOR: It's not.
And that's because
you can actually--
can perturb them
almost instantaneous,
slam with perturbation.
And so they can't
anticipate this.
And you actually can see, within
one step, a cockroach step,
they'll spring back, and their
center of mass trajectory
will get back on track.
And so it's not like they see
something coming or there's--
they're going to step something
that's going to hit them.
It's that there's just-- they're
running along, a perturbation,
and then they start
bouncing right away.
I'm sorry about this.
I don't know what's
happening here.
Yeah.
I'll have to--
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So in that
model, is it now the spring
is actually [INAUDIBLE] Because
now that you have x, y, z,
and it's at an
angle, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean you--
AUDIENCE: Is that
how you do that, or--
PROFESSOR: If you're
doing the lateral plane,
I think you have to have some
sort of springiness like that
that can push you through.
But you can actually look at
the cockroach running along
the sagittal plane, and you
don't need the [INAUDIBLE] You
can--
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can treat
several legs if they're just
like one spring in the tripod.
If there's something called--
I don't know if you've seen--
you know Bob Full's work at all
and these templates and anchors,
where the anchors are the more
complicated system,
and the templates
are these really
simplified systems?
So your SLIP little
thing here can
be like a template, which
is a really minimalist model
but captures some of
the essential dynamics
and does so in a concise way.
And you can look at just
a cockroach as following
this kind of running.
I mean, and it actually
captures a lot of it.
I mean, there's more
complicated ones.
If you look at the lateral
plane dynamics, I mean,
you probably need a
more complicated model.
But so--
AUDIENCE: What did you say
this model was called again?
PROFESSOR: This is a SLIP.
Oh, but [INAUDIBLE] and
Buehler came with this.
So this is-- yeah, it
has a mass of the toe.
I don't know if it
has a different--
I don't think it has
a different name.
Yeah, so let me get to this.
There you go.
All right.
So first, the less
exciting thing, I think,
right here, but
still pretty cool.
So measuring the force on
these cockroaches' steps,
you could imagine, is difficult.
Something they did, actually,
to facilitate these experiments
is they actually have
these guys running on Jello.
I think he set up diffraction
[INAUDIBLE] on this jello.
And so you see
that, how it changes
color when they're pushing?
They're actually
able to figure out
the magnitude and the
direction of the force
to some level of accuracy
by looking at that.
And apparently, orange
jello works really well.
I don't know what it
is about orange jello,
but if you ever want to analyze
the forces on a cockroach's
legs, start with orange jello,
if that's the only thing you
get out of this lecture.
But yeah, so that's pretty
cool, but that's just
analyzing when it's turning.
They can figure out-- that's to
look at some of the springiness
and how the force response and
the center of mass response
connect.
But here.
This is one of the greatest
experiments of all time
right here.
All right, so this is looking
at the perturbation experienced
by these cockroaches.
So what they did, they
bolt a cannon to the back,
because pulling strings
and stuff like that,
it's not fast enough.
It's nowhere near fast enough.
This cockroach is running.
Aw, come on.
What's going on here?
All right.
Really sorry.
It's running.
Bam.
Perturbation.
The little cannonball actually
hits it on the way back,
you see.
[LAUGHTER]
That's not really fair.
That's double perturbation.
But they tracked the
center of mass of this guy,
and actually, you
could see it gets back
on in less than a step.
And if you look at
the time scale of this
and the time scale of
their monosynaptic reflex,
it happens too quickly.
And so they think it's
actually compliance
in the legs and everything
like that that's just passively
tuned such that it gets banged
to the side and rights itself.
AUDIENCE: Will you put
this on the course website?
PROFESSOR: Actually, I think--
I mean, it's Bob Full's video,
but he may have it available.
But a great thing is that
the guy who did this thing--
Devin did it.
And he said-- and
this is all he said,
so he didn't go
through the full thing.
But he's like,
you'd be surprised
by how little gunpowder
is necessary to perturb
a cockroach.
[LAUGHTER]
And so you could only
imagine the first cockroach
they got out there.
And they're like ah, this is
about the right amount and just
blows the cockroach up or
launches it across the room
or--
so that would have been a fun
trial in an experiment to watch
from a different room, I think.
Yeah, we'll watch
this one more time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
But you see, that's just
a fantastic little experiment.
And the perturbation,
as you see--
I mean, it doesn't
know that's coming.
That hits it like that.
It just responds
almost instantaneously.
So I think that's really cool.
And that shows this--
I mean that's SLIP
in the lateral plane.
And it shows that these
springs and this compliance
in the actual--
in the animal can
actually do things
that just a control
couldn't do, that the time
scale of the response
can be faster
than control could achieve.
I don't know if I have--
yeah, I don't think I
have these [INAUDIBLE]
So does anybody have a question?
Yeah.
OK, so that's nature having
this spring bouncy compliance.
But you can see Raibert's
hoppers, back in just the '80s
and '90s, did
amazing things, too.
If you look at--
let's see, where's
this 1-D monoped?
There.
Some of these videos are
pretty crappy, but there.
So that's just a little
monoped running around.
Do you see?
And I mean, it's constrained
to be in the plane.
It's on a boom, but it
could fall down forward
and everything like that.
It's not like it's free to roll.
So it's achieved the stability
bouncing around that circle.
But thought they could do more
than that if you look at--
they built bipeds.
This is-- I think, yeah, Russ
grabbed this from a VHS tapes.
So this is actually
what's funny is
that I think this is the
fastest biped around,
but it wasn't quite that fast.
That's skipping frames,
but I think it's still--
unless something has
changed in the last year.
It runs like 2.2
meters a second,
which I think is actually
still the fastest biped.
But Russ would know if
anything has changed.
AUDIENCE: Is it spinning around?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I'm sorry.
It looks like it's spinning
around but it's not [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Oh.
But check out that.
So here-- oh, come on.
There.
So they figured
they could do more.
Here's a biped.
So this one isn't on a boom.
Bam.
Check that out.
Look at this one more time.
Running there, [INAUDIBLE]
speed, like gymnastics.
That's like a robot
doing a front flip.
Then here, this is
pretty impressive, too.
Yeah.
Right over those stairs
like nobody's business.
AUDIENCE: Is there a [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If what
were out of phase?
If the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If the stairs
were out of phase?
I don't know.
You could probably
imagine setting up
stairs that would make
it easier and stairs
that would make it harder.
So yeah, you probably
could come up
with something that would be
problematic if it had to hop.
Well, maybe could hop
on one foot for a while.
I don't know.
It's on a boom.
But yeah, so I mean, these are--
I mean, even now, you can look
at these things, and you're--
I mean, they would be amazing
if someone just achieved this,
but these were back in the '80s
and '90s that people did this.
And so I mean, you've
probably seen Big Dog.
Raibert worked on Big Dog, too,
and it's like 20 years later
than this stuff.
And it's still state of the
art, that kind of control
and similar control
in a lot of ways.
We can do some more of these.
Oh.
Oh, there's one
that's-- let's see.
and the thing is
that not only do
these guys do
these crazy things,
but their robustness is
really pretty incredible.
I mean, a lot of these,
like the Honda robots
walk on, carefully, just ground
and everything like that.
Here.
[INAUDIBLE] towing him along.
It's probably not
the most comfortable.
It looks like it's a
little bit less smooth.
But I mean, it's running along
sidewalks outside of MIT.
They have-- this other one's
[INAUDIBLE] just running
by itself on grass
and everything, too.
Oh, the quadrupeds
are pretty cool, too.
That's a quadruped
running down the hallway.
And they actually
did a cool paper
called "Four Legs Running
as One," "Four Legs that
Run as One," something--
"Running With Four Legs as if
it Were One"-- there we go--
that used the same
kind of control ideas
but actually can
get these quadrupeds
and actually run based
on the same ideas.
And you see that thing's moving
pretty fast and pretty robustly
right down hallway like that.
So it's really pretty amazing
capabilities, even today.
There's one I really wish
I could find for you.
Yeah.
And so interesting thing
that some more recent work,
they've--
oh, let's look at
[INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
Check that out.
Isn't that just amazing, right?
And actuators that these guys
use is hydraulics at the hips
and then pneumatics
along the leg,
so _?}
with a pneumatic.
Need that so you can
rocket yourself that far.
But it's just incredible.
Yeah.
So something that people
are working on more recently
is this thing
called SLIP walkers.
So you can imagine if you have a
compass gait with springy legs,
right, as it's spring
constant gets very high,
it starts behaving just
like a compass gait.
If the spring constant goes
to infinity, it's rigid,
it's going to be just
like a compass gait.
If you let those strings
get looser and looser,
it's going to start
being more like one
of these bouncy bipeds, right,
more like this SLIP behavior.
And so actually, you can
get stability properties--
I mean, it can be stable
through a relatively broad range
of bounciness so that the
same robot can vault over
its legs and walking
and then start
bouncing and start running.
It actually could
do that transition.
And that's a cool anything
also that you see.
I should have brought
this up at the beginning
when we were talking
about biology.
But those transitions
are interesting,
because if you look
at the efficiency
of human locomotion-- so you
can measure O2 consumption,
and you can see how efficient it
is to walk at different speeds
and to run at different speeds.
You can look at the
efficiency curve for--
I believe this is speed, and
this is, let's say, efficiency.
And so you have
something with walking
and some curve like this.
And then running, you
have some curve like this.
I mean, quantitatively,
these could be wrong,
but this is a
qualitative feature.
So if you look at the
efficiency of a person walking
and you just put
them on a treadmill
and just tell them, start
walking, speed it up, speed it
up, and tell them
just to transition
to running whenever they want,
they'll transition right here.
That switches.
And so you know the
feeling, I'm sure,
where you're walking
faster and faster
and suddenly it just feels
more comfortable to just start
jogging.
Apparently, that happens when
the efficiency of that motion
outweighs that of walking,
because obviously you
can walk where it's
uncomfortable to walk and run
where it's uncomfortable to run.
But the natural transition
happens at that efficiency,
bifurcation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
Yeah, that should be cost.
Now it's even more skewed.
There we go.
Thank you.
Yeah, so [INAUDIBLE]
SLIP walkers, I think.
Hopefully, you can get
some of this in transition,
but I'm not sure exactly
where they are right now.
I don't know if they
have any videos of those.
There's some papers about them.
And I think that's all the stuff
that Russ wanted me to convey.
So we just have some
idea of this culture
of these cool running models
and these springy things
and these preflexes and
stuff, and in nature,
the fact that springs are
critical to locomotion
of horses and the stability
of the cockroach running
and everything like that.
So if anyone has
any questions, I'd
love to answer them
about anything.
AUDIENCE: When you were
saying how they were--
the transitioning using the
spring model between walking
to running--
PROFESSOR: Oh, the SLIP walkers?
AUDIENCE: Hmm?
PROFESSOR: The SLIP walkers?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
the SLIP walkers.
Is it still [INAUDIBLE]
elastic collision,
or do they [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think in practice.
I think they have
idealized legs.
I think they've done
simulations idealized legs, too.
But you can do either
way, I'm pretty sure.
I haven't looked at
that work as closely
as I probably should have.
But yeah, for the walking,
vaulting behavior,
you need either a toe
thing that's going to--
or you can let your spring
constant go to infinity.
And then you'll have
a rigid impact, right.
So you can treat
it that way, too.
But then yeah, if
you loosen it up,
then you're not going to have
the intermediate still lossy
behavior.
But yeah, I think
they have done stuff
with idealized legs and probably
non-idealized ones, too.
So anything else?
AUDIENCE: If you
get it just right,
can you adjust the
spring constant so
that you'll get the push
off right before landing?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you
mean toe off, kind of,
or the toe-off thing
that pushes you
forward that
[INAUDIBLE] efficiency?
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: I think you should--
I mean, I'm not sure
about how the tuning would
relate to the walking things.
But when you have these
idealized legs with the spring,
I mean, you can't
be more efficient
than if you're
vaulting over them.
So I don't know if
it connects to the--
I mean, it seems like it could
connect to that toe off launch,
but I'm not sure if
that is explicit,
just by having your
leg not be a strike
with the dissipative inelastic
collision is going to help you.
But I don't know if you get
the same kind of-- yeah,
it seems like you should, but
I don't know if that exact
point--
I haven't seen that exact point.
But it could easily be
addressed in other papers.
Yeah, I should--
I don't know if I have
the references right now,
but I can make sure that
Russ gives those to your
or get those to you
myself next lecture
if you want to look up
some of the SLIP walkers,
because that's pretty
new stuff, I think.
Yeah.